the north american last chance qualifier
for valerian champions finally finished
up last weekend and there is a lot to
talk about in the valerian community
cloud9 blue is going to champs but there
is so much more we have to discuss if
anything we have learned that the north
american valorant scene has so many
rising stars and the world better be
ready
[Music]
all right y'all i gotta remind you to
hit that subscribe button and that
notification bell as well as to like and
comment on this video it's that or
forgot to feed gobo this morning
and he's hungry alright friends we
finally made it even after a player
losing power in overtime causing yet
another delay
we have finally finished the lcq tell
your friends and tell the world we
finally have our last north american
team who is going to champions the
gentlemen of cloud9 blue are going to be
the third team alongside sentinels and
envy to represent north america in the
very first valor in champions which if
you're not familiar with the
nomenclature is more or less valerent
worlds zeta zeppa vanity leaf and mitch
punched their ticket and they did so in
fabulous fashion by only dropping one
set making a dominant lower bracket run
and finally beating rise in the grand
finals 3-0
[Music]
but it wasn't easy getting there cloud9
blue's roster not to be confused with
cloud9 white which dominates game
changers has seen a bunch of changes
before landing on this winning crew if
you remember this past season this
roster has been a revolving door names
like floppy relics vice shinobi tens
this team has seen a lot of changes but
the one person has seen all of them come
and go
mitch mitch was announced as a cloud 9
blue player on july 15 2020 and he
hasn't moved since he's the only player
left from the original roster he has
played a bunch of different agents and
even at one point was the team's igl
before vanity came over from version one
mid august 2021 mitch has had a year and
a half of a lot of changes to adjust to
without a lot of success but finally his
patience has paid off and he's made it
uh yeah i mean it was a lot of ups and
downs since i first joined cloud9 like a
year and a half ago went through so many
roster changes
a lot of heartbreaks a lot of finals
lost a lot of qualifiers against
you know vanity that we lost
so it definitely feels great to finally
make one after all the hard work for the
past year and a half with uh cloud9
given this weekend stellar result it
seems like vanity may have been the
missing piece of the puzzle to put it
all together for cloud9 blue he has
proven that his reputation as an in-game
leader going all the way back to
counter-strike is no joke and if you
look at this roster there is a massive
connection between cloud9 blue and this
little any team known as chaos esports
and if you're new to the world of any
tactical fps esports and don't know who
that is
don't worry baby i got you chaos esports
is an organization that had a north
american counter-strike roster this
roster included vanities zepa leaf as
well as steel the steel connection's
important we're gonna come back to that
later so these three had a lot of
experience together if you heard people
calling this team chaos9 this is the
reason why now you can tell all your
friends that you knew that and be cooler
than them like i said baby i got you
chaos was a roster in the nacs scene
that was actually all released in early
2021. there were a lot of moving parts
vanity had an impressive run with
version one in iceland and became the
core of the team's eventual reunion now
they're showing signs of the team that
nacs fans fell in love with anyways c9
blue was cohesive and impressive but i
would not be doing my job if i did not
talk about some of the other teams with
a very impressive second place finish we
have the underdogs
rise ryze might be considered the
underdogs having their cinderella moment
at the lcq ryze didn't believe that they
were the underdogs but they took that
name and they let it inspire them we're
feeling great because
we love being the underdog
i just love how everyone thinks like
we're not gonna win so it just gives us
extra motivation going into every single
map and i just make them more fun too
afterwards rise consists of neptune
supermen derrick poised and shanks and
honestly they are incredible to watch
swing with me shouldn't they come come
come
on
nice
[Music]
ryze have proven themselves to be an
incredible team to watch as well as a
hard team to be including a now iconic
fake against 100 thieves did they lose
on split 13-0 against c9 blue
yes yes they did but throughout the
tournament they demonstrated great map
control good gun play as well as proving
that you can clap back at this tweet
from phase baby bay for the last time i
do not look like at all i'm looking at
you comment section again he's a good
looking dude but like
i just don't see it also rise went on to
win that set against faze and send them
to the lower bracket rice stayed in the
upper bracket until the grand finals
beating teams like faze 100 thieves
cloud9 blue
obviously some of the best teams in the
region so now we talk about the elephant
in the room for some of you and that is
100 thieves 100 thieves had a very
interesting journey up until the lcq
they competed in masters 3 berlin and
probably had the most star-studded
lineup in the world aside from sentinels
steel was their igl but an announcement
was made on september 27th that 100
thieves would be benching him boy would
be taking his place with seven as a new
substitute in july when boy originally
joined there was talk that he was going
to be on the roster but it was confirmed
that he was just joining as an analyst
but after benching steel 100 thieves
brought in boy as the fifth man in an
interview with upcomer boy said that
quote i actually thought it was a smooth
transition i'm playing a role that i
previously played on my past team in
terms of roles it was perfect and
everyone on the team is gelling really
well so if you are doing the math the
announcement of steel's benching came
just two weeks before the lcq was
supposed to start with steel out nitro
was the acting igl for the lcq but it
wasn't enough 100 thieves fell to rise
in the upper bracket finals then once
again to cloud9 blue in the lower
bracket finals hearts pounding handshake
and this is possibly the final retake
hundred thieves has before the lower
bracket rise come up with two they
started off three members of hundred
three sand ethan comes up with a frag is
this gonna be enough nitro not able to
get it just yet and it's gonna be kiko
who leaps out of the window rise have
secured their last chance on the road to
champions he go watching the flank first
he looks away
stephan
they're second guessing their angles
it's not working as boy comes up with a
big frag it's up to him the newest
member of the team can he keep this
series alive boy staying in the oh he
gets hit by zeppa that's gonna be the
defuse there's more than enough time
cloud nine lock in grand finals they'll
face raise to get revenge i would call
this a pretty big disappointment for n a
fans like if i told you at the beginning
of the year that 100 thieves would not
be playing in champs
you would have called me crazy well some
of you would have called me crazy
regardless cloud9 blue let the world
know that this was not only for
themselves but for steel remember that
connection i talked about before all of
you try playing armchair experts and try
to dictate what 100 thieves should have
done regarding benching steel and
bringing someone else on or whatever
let me just say one last thing you are
not in their scrims you are not in their
practice rooms you are not on the team
so before you go off sending undeserved
hate to boy or whoever just think about
that for a second look i understand i
have a lot of questions and feelings
about the situation and i love
valrant do not listen to this clip of me
being jump scared accidentally reloading
and then saying i hate the game
but i am not going to pretend i know
more about the game and team comps and
so much more than the man whose job it
is to know these things c9 blue will be
competing in berlin with the best teams
from across the world but for teams like
ryze 100 thieves faze luminosity gen g
except version one this is the end of
their competitive year we don't know how
the next champions tour will look or how
orgs will adjust their rosters plays you
name it what we can say for sure is that
n a has proven to be a hell of a force
be reckoned with in the valerian scene
so
let's look forward to not only december
1st with champions but the months to
come where n a ballerina can only get
better i'm going to emphasize the word
can they might not it could be all
downhill from here i'm not sure i'm a
yankees fan i kind of just expect to
lose
but hopefully with n.a ballerin that all
changes
again he's a good looking dude but like
i just don't see it
do i need to get like a like like a
necklace he wears those chains right
i'll i should have been him for
halloween
dang it
anyways
who are you for halloween i'm faze baby